thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
where today we get super super serious
we are potentially allegedly I don't
know hypothetically on the verge of
World War III
some questions whether you had those
questions or not what are you doing to
get ready for us in America going to war
with China and Russia okay so I just
found out about this so I don't really
have much time
it's China Russia getting together
against America it seems like that right
I mean somebody correct me if I'm wrong
but that kind of sounds like powerful
force right it's it's definitely scary
when are we gonna get everybody to do
World Peace Michael Jackson's dead bro
oh we are the world is not gonna work
does it make sense for us well I am he
makes songs like that too you know who I
think can make this happen we are the
world and it's Ramen
I don't even know what he's doing he
already tried didn't he I mean he got us
in North Korea he I'm telling you Trump
would have never met
if it wasn't for Dennis Ramen first
being the [__] American embassy of
basketball like hey dude you got to meet
my dude Kim Jong like he's real chill so
you need we need like we need like Trump
Dennis Rodman and Steven Seagal in a
room to figure it out Steven seagulls
he's all Russia now you can slam him I
think he's jump ship he I think he's
like oh he's starting a new Aikido
studio in Moscow dude America has been
too mean to him do you want to hear some
real thoughts yeah well do you honestly
do you want to hear some real thoughts
because I'm a to be honest I'm a little
scared I've been exploring it and just
not like thinking about it in the
general space
so like let's say it's like not too big
of a threat because no one wants the
whole world to turn into a toaster oven
so they might be doing like Cyber Wars
or satellite Wars or like that kind of
[__] robot war yeah where it doesn't
really affect unless you the common
person directly like your roof's not
gonna explode maybe the economy tanks
and the loaf of bread is 20 bucks those
I think are make are easier adjustments
because we can all still do whatever we
do in our life and make small
adjustments like maybe Nick has to
charge more for personal training or
whatever so there's that level where I
feel like where I feel like that's when
it's helpful to have savings because you
can kind of weather the storm and the
economic Realm
if it gets to the point where it's like
my white glove slap to your face and
then China and us are actually gonna
[__] duke it out like as in missiles
and [__]
if that's the case I wouldn't be opposed
to re-enlisting
because at that point I personally think
the economy might be so [__] up that I
might actually need a job so what better
than to just already be on the side of
already having a job and then at least
your family's taken care of they can
live on base I feel like you know that
kind of [__] you wouldn't feel like
like your own friends would turn on you
because you're a ching chong
nah because I think they'll be like this
guy was Korean in the Marine Corps oh
okay okay okay so yeah you're racial
fluid yeah racial fluid yeah and it's
pretty cool and then if it's like
[__]
um
like Normandy action but over here oh
man like straight up Bridges so the [__]
hits the fan hits the fan
I might go like
and then just go to China and try to
blend it
how do you how would you do that you
have to wear a body sweater or some [__]
your tattoos all over there no I try to
be I've been Chinese the whole time I
don't know
I'm not gonna I thought about that and
I'm not then I'm I'm [__] around but
I'm kind of serious you know like I know
I could if you don't know what level of
threat it's gonna be you know what I
mean I know Chinese families that would
house me but I mean I ain't trying to
turn tail on right away you know
trainers to The Republic that's what I'm
saying you just missed this whole murder
cup no no I know but then I would be I
would have to I would have to turn you
in
I would be like hey call the ambulance
but not for me
how many Chinese in in like Western
countries do you think would run to
China when they ran away from China
see that's the that's the best question
I think in today's generation I don't
know how many of them actually ran away
from China versus they came here for
like certain types of other
opportunities they ran away from
communism it depends on the beef so if
my dad won they ran away from China so
if my dad was still alive he would
enlist in the American Military because
like do you believe that he's had yeah
sure because the pain that he has had
from China hurts way more and after he
came here his life has skyrocketed
China's like his why do we watch the
Chinese military parade on repeat
I think he watches it as a cultural it's
like us watching like old dog you know
it's like me watching the Nazis March no
no it's like us watching it's like him
watching Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
it's just like a cultural oh so it's not
like it's celebrating the Chinese blood
but not Chinese politics oh God I got it
got it yeah and this isn't necessarily a
war on polit I mean obviously it is to a
degree but this isn't necessarily the
same as like communism versus democracy
we're talking about like it's just world
powers yeah it's like world power right
and economies and stuff so it seems
different I think my legitimate answer
is I go in the ground like as much as I
can go underground like like what you
mean like you would end up in China
not that deep that's way too deep Bugs
Bunny said uh you know keep digging no I
would I would try to you know there's
tunnel system under Vegas you know
yeah I got a question okay so let's say
China obviously outnumbers us like crazy
and then for the us if we're not going
nuclear they're like we need every
able-bodied man that we can get because
our military is just not big enough and
then they're just like from the ages of
like 14 to like
fifth no 60. you can if you can pull the
[__] gun you gotta go oh that means
all of us are in there right that means
Dante Bosco is going to yeah would you
go
would you go I mean we know bar will
because he's been in the military I'm
familiar with the system yeah but isn't
it you can't get in if you're 39 or some
[__] there's uh yeah that you can age
out but he's in his scenario you're like
that's what I'm saying like from 14 yeah
to [__] 60. it's like the ending of
Independence Day let me do careful boys
you if you got a beating heart and you
can pull a trigger you're in you're
gonna be drafted geez okay well he's
drafted that's not much of a choice
right draft is yeah if it's drafted and
then you're drafted here's the trick if
they're gonna draft but you volunteer
first you can choose your job yep and if
you choose your job and if you choose in
the medical field you're not in a
non-combat Zone hacksaw Ridge right up
top if you want to stay alive you want
to be in a non-combat Zone well what if
you're like they're like okay perfect
you're a combat medic and you're like oh
no it's not technically a medical job in
the military do you need like a be like
a nurse or some [__] like what's that
considered a combat medic is technically
you're still infantry man but you just
it's like the radio operator
yeah a combat medic is still technically
an infantry person does anyone even
coming that's that guy
yeah that's see you know there's there's
that also that feeling uh again drafting
it's like you don't really have a choice
you know so it's like but if you had a
choice let's just say America needs you
14 or 60 year olds America needs you
it's not a draft but you so you have the
choice if you don't go to your draft
Dodger social shame social shame for how
long it would be complex to answer that
at the moment I do have beloved ties to
the motherland of China in different
ways uh however I will say that there's
always just like when 9 11 happened and
yes I don't deny in this hyper in this
case you don't deny it yeah yeah but
there's also an extreme feeling a
patriot patriotism when you're like your
motherland your your home soil gets
attacked some like [__] treacherous
way right let's say like China actually
started bombing like metropolitan areas
like our my family was actually under
threat then at that point it's not about
you don't [__] up yeah it's just like
I'm gonna go [__] fight whoever's
bombing my my family yeah you know what
I mean that has nothing to do with like
my blood Heritage that's like no my
family's getting bombed I must stop that
person where do you think you would fit
in in terms of like what you could
contribute based off of his secrets I'm
just gonna [__] apply for the
non-contact yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh maybe oh no sometimes cooks are
sent out do you think you can eat
because they need to entertain me you
think you could like get away with like
just doing some dances and stuff if I
could do that like how some of the guys
in Korea do when they sign up for like
their army because they have to go for
like a year and a half nowadays yeah but
they're like entertaining people they
just go to the different bases and
perform [__] yeah I don't give a [__]
I'll be dancing like a monkey jeez but
if I gotta go over there dance like a
monkey oh man what dude guaranteed if
you guys look Chinese speak Chinese
they're gonna use y'all for like
Espionage [__] do you think I look
Chinese a thousand percent I don't speak
Chinese though [__] in general you look
Chinese as a mother all right
he told me in the Espionage in Russia
man do you think I look Chinese
yeah
to General Eisenhower we all look
Chinese dude
man I thought I was Korean dude they
can't use it on the battlefield because
they might get confused that would be
that'll be crazy I've been married a
half asian lady is the other guy throw
me into it yeah yeah I just tell on her
I'll be good right yeah I'm just like
hey you gotta pick this one up she's
gonna be like I'm calling the ambulance
but not for me oh I have another
football so oh how in Arizona
and uh we had some fans that were
serving us at a restaurant and she was
like oh you should come check out our
reservation and then I was like oh what
because she's a Native American and I'm
like oh cool and then um
I don't know we could just come and
they're like oh actually you can't you
have to like wear a mask or whatever but
like all the rest of Arizona they don't
wear a mask anymore they're like oh we
actually have our own president and our
own I was like oh [__] I forgot their
like their own Sovereign Nation yeah so
if we got some Native American hookups
maybe we could sneak into the
reservation and maybe we could become a
member of their truck
Marianne knuckle they're not gonna that
you're gonna be like who's gonna
available Pocahontas yeah but
technically Asians cross the Bering
Strait and came to the U.S uh anciently
so we might have close DNA somehow you
know what I mean like something you say
before you get shot dude yeah
you never know yeah we might have to
hook up we'll see okay I'm gonna try to
find every loophole though if [__] hits
the fan I gotta I gotta explore all
options and then what's all the
loopholes and then try to figure out the
best [__] I saw Nikki's wedding ring
immediately
did Wayne do that for a long time anyway
then we take the cash and we try to get
we try to leave leave the country you
guys would literally go to a
non-conflict area
so okay so let's say that was the first
thing let's say let's say there's war on
U.S soil California is being invaded
Hawaii's ordinance I say good get go
ahead and get California you can spend
time there if you want newsom's house
first dude they might do a better job
California sucks
so they got Ryan Anthony all these
stragglers that decided to stay in
California you guys are in Vegas you
already did for sure I'm dead for sure
dude I'm [__] out there serving a
Waikiki punch and we got nuked
you turned into a skeleton whoa that's
what I'm saying she turned to a skeleton
I'm I'm actually live I was teaching
workshops no Shadow dude you're in
California Chinese wise do like workouts
you know who won't be a shadow holding
the [__] boba tea David so because he
doesn't the ideas guys yeah yeah
is that some fancy fancy restaurant
somewhere is it some Hollywood [__]
rooftop party having all these uh
Hollywood Asian guys tell them I
secretly like you but I can't talk about
it
is it relatively safe to be like a tank
Tech or something
hey what job will we all have in the
military what could you see us like with
our skills be nice be honest be nice be
honest skill is a monkey he said like a
monkey it's hard to be honest he's
looking for every loophole in the game I
know what I'm gonna do but go ahead if I
were to be honest
Nick could be a combatives instructor so
self-defense hand probably get knocked
out oh he's not gonna get killed because
he's an instructor
deflector I feel like Urban Shield I
feel like Steve would be some sort of
like encrypted Intel specialist someone
that can crack the code see what the
[__] going on yeah look there's Matrix
zeros Computer Guy this is the hottest
you've ever been in my life thank you
what about combatives instructor
Anthony I think would be the chaplain
the what the chaplain what the [__] is
that like a religious figure the guy who
does oh yeah the guy who's like who's
like praying while you're dying yeah
before people go out to die oh [__]
that's what I was gonna do yeah the
reason why is I think you're a very
emotionally intelligent person and you
empathize so much with everyone so I
think when people have hard times you
can help them that's what I was gonna do
Escape escape the war it's also the
sweetest thing you've ever said to me it
kind of look like a cool Pastor anyway
dude
or Anthony could be the guy so like you
know how they they do not intelligence
but you know how they do like shows like
to like propagandize and Inspire the
military yeah like Uso shows like
Captain America no no you're like the
the Chinese guy who's dancing like
running away from the the troops were
like oh and the Captain America kills
him yeah exactly like and then you like
going like
but it's a dancer and they're throwing
eggs
[Applause]
I'm walking backstage [__] joke off
my face you're like another egg I'm like
yeah two dozen today just go over the
salad that's so funny yeah make sure
when you're [__] dying on the front
lines I'm not praying for you okay oh
make sure not to crack any of your coats
I can see Joe as a machine gunner either
on the top of a tank
it's that rage mode he'll go [__] ham
and he's good at games too so he'll just
go
destroy it like Berserker like he killed
his old Squad
[Laughter]
there's just no one left he just like
saw man there's just no
no left
it's like he turned our whole Squad into
chili dude everybody everybody oh
there's not even pigeons dude I got him
out of the sky everything last man
standing Wildlife pigeons are extinct
and I can see a rhino may be in some
sort of special ops like disguise ninja
guy where he has all these special
tricks and knows how to like is he
Indian or is he
is he Mexican who knows honestly I see
Ryan too doing like something musically
to inspire people like who are in the
field and [__] oh yeah look at Mad Max
guitar guy well dude because you were on
a flaming truck um you were off camera
yesterday telling us about how or no you
were on camera but you were talking
about how you take the intensity of like
when these girls are doing oh oh okay
like [__] score into it but yeah like
on the battlefield you're like pumping
everybody up scoring to the floor
everybody's got one airpods
that would be an American tactic it's
like back in the day they had the
drummer boy
that's like but you're gonna do some
Gangsta [__] it's gonna be like
and then we're all like [__] yeah we're
gonna like send me all the dying people
so I can say something nice to them
right before they die but I can't take
it anymore Anthony talk to me all right
let's see
I think China's fully invaded right
we're just [__] like we're not even
addressing Russia by the way oh we're on
the ground their troops are on our
ground now yeah and we're just like [__]
now what are these rushes on the East
Coast
yeah Russia's on the East Coast China's
on the west coast oh now we're just kind
of like post it's just like yeah yeah we
gotta go it's like imagine like when
like it's like Nazi Germany right and
then like it's just in the middle of War
just soldiers everywhere we're just
regular civilians what would you do
would you join an Insurgency group like
a rebel group
like our military is failing
I don't know what we're gonna do how
crazy is a situation like are we still
getting broadcast on TV like there's
still General infrastructure or it's
like all traffic lights are just
flashing red probably be like yeah you
go to downtown it's just internet
doesn't work for anybody yeah China
um believes that um you can't really go
to war in mainland United States because
there would be a gun behind every blade
of grass yeah I think that was like
maybe 30 years ago yeah now there's like
say there's like a coward behind
everybody like we're all talking about
running away and [__] hiding and
going on a [__] talk [__] on the
internet though we're gonna be like what
are the serial killers now where are the
mass Shooters now come out yeah come get
some yeah exactly like if if China was
to invade us where would a good point be
to like
to take first if I was helping them yeah
in the entire country where would the
where would the Normandy be well you
probably for sure take out Hawaii
I know but you can't get to California
unless you get to Hawaii you gotta
destroy the entire Pacific food the
reason there's so many babies that is
like their point as like the whole
Pacific Theater and it's far enough yeah
it's far enough where if you hit Hawaii
they can get everyone ready on the west
coast and have plenty of time because
it's like five hours away even by flight
you know damn
or you skip it because like jumby's
there and yeah
they respect matcha too they respect
Boba and Macho but they have it bro
maybe what they could do is dress up
Catalina Island like Hawaii and like
them when they can play Catalina one
yeah yeah
damn yeah people pull the dancing on
[__] Catalina yeah and then they blow
that up and then they're like we got in
Hawaii and then we're like oh you're in
Catalina Island
how did we [__] that up
that would be crazy I wouldn't know I
think the best way to invade the US is
hire all the hottest Tick Tock girls and
only fans girls that was the game the
whole that was the game and then get
them distracted because you just have
one event it's called it's called the
D-Day
because it's you get your dicks out it's
a double D Day right and then all the
girls show up at the beach Santa Monica
Beach right because that's where all the
influencers go and then everyone's go
like oh [__] what the [__] is happening
there's just so much and then they have
uh synchronized torque session and they
don't know that they're getting paid by
China it's just Tick Tock is sponsoring
them right right and that's when the
Chinese go okay they distracted go and
then like well everyone's like
mesmerized from the booty shaking they
[__] run but where were they the
whole time Chinese people are bum
rushing it down
up the beach they're finally invading
right but Who's Gonna Save Us is the
Gaze of West Hollywood because they're
immune right yeah so they're like wait
what what do these Chinese guys doing
yeah and they're immune to booty shaking
so they're gonna be like hey does
anybody join the bully there's there's
Chinese guys and then they're gonna be
they're gonna snap out of it like oh
[__] we're getting invaded see it can I
ask you can I ask you for this question
have you ever have you ever seen gay
guys in West Hollywood actually reacting
to chicks twerking no because they're
like get it honey let's [__] go I
think everybody would probably be
distracted they they get on their and
put their legs on the wall and start
shaking too
and it's a big party
that's that's white if we're talking
stereotypes
China's gonna win
[Music]